la taiga siberiana iluminada ante la
oscuridad de la noche por el fuego que
la devora los bosques del norte de rusia
también han sido por varias semanas foco
de los incendios con 1.5 millones de
hectáreas convertidas en humo la
atmósfera se empieza a volver
inhabitable estamos rodeados de
incendios apenas puedo respirar no sé ni
cómo proteger a mis hijos si bien es
cierto los incendios forestales en
verano en siberia son comunes la sequía
de este año está haciendo que
combatirlos sea más difícil estos
hombres han estado luchando contra los
incendios en vano
mis hijos y yo hemos estado luchando
para apagar el fuego durante 17 días sin
tener uno solo de descanso nadie ve
en el norte del líbano las llamas han
devastado laderas y huertos y han
amenazado poblaciones cuyos habitantes
luchan por apagar con recursos limitados
no hay defensa civil no hay cruz roja
nada estamos solos mira hemos perdido
nuestras posesiones nuestras viviendas y
una persona ha perdido la vida
hemos sido abandonados maltratan en
sicilia los bomberos sufren para
controlar los incendios forestales en
las afueras de catania en medio de la
ola de calor mientras tanto varios
incendios han amenazado el sur de
turquía algunos turistas en la playa
pudieron grabar las imágenes del humo
mientras las autoridades intentan apagar
los numerosos focos con helicópteros
anfibios los incendios en turquía dejan
al menos 180 personas heridas mientras
que varias han perdido la vida